a habit is a redundant set of automatic
unconscious thoughts behaviors and
emotions that's acquired through
repetition
a habit is when you've done something so
many times that the body now knows how
to do it better than the mind
so now the person
running through the same routine every
single day is on autopilot and their
body's now dragging them
into a predictable future based on what
they did in the past and they've lost
their free will
to a set of programs right so now you
have the familiar past and you have the
predictable future those are knowns
so the only place then reasonably where
the unknown exists is the sweet spot of
the generous present moment that is when
the body and mind are free from those
conditions so along with those emotions
that influence the same thoughts
people start becoming more judgmental
they start becoming more impatient they
start becoming more entitled
they start getting more afraid more
anxious more depressed and now the body
is literally being depleted
of energy because it's believing that
it's living in an emergency situation
and in emergency you tap all the body's
resources for some threat whether it's
real or imagined
and so then when you're releasing all of
these chemicals we are literally drawing
the body's life force and turning it
into chemistry and so for the short term
that's cool
but the arousal that's created from
those stress hormones
is a rush of energy
and so then people use the problems
and the conditions in their life to
reaffirm their conditioning or their
addiction to that emotion
and in a sense they become addicted to
the life they don't even like
and this is why change is so hard
so then when a person makes up their
mind to change and they say okay i'm not
going to say i can't i'm not going to
judge another person i'm not going to
blame i'm not going to complain i'm not
going to make excuses i'm not going to
be a victim i'm not going to talk trash
about anybody i'm just going to stop
well that works out really well for the
first couple hours
then the bodies sing you're out of
schedule you normally at eight in the
morning you're getting traffic and
you're angry then at 11 o'clock you
check your emails and you're really
judgmental and frustrated the body's
saying well you've been doing this for
the last 20 years you're just going to
stop today so now the body which has
been conditioned emotionally to be the
mind wants to return back to its
familiar territory to the known
so the body starts influencing the mind
and it says you know come on
this is a good time to judge that come
on this is a good time to suffer it's
your ex's fault it's it's your it's the
government's fault it's uh
you know it's the weather what the news
whatever it is and if we
accept
believe and surrender to that thought
without analyzing it it slips by and it
begins to program the autonomic nervous
system to make those pharmacy of
chemicals
and so that's when the person makes the
same choice
does the same thing
creates the same experience just for
that familiar feeling
okay i'll complain just so i can feel
suffering then
they'd rather
be unhappy
and step into the unknown to step into
possibility and the hardest part about
that process
first of all is not making the same
choice as you did day before
and here's the payoff
you got to stay conscious
and not go unconscious and it turns out
that 95 of the time we're unconscious so
if you're going to stay conscious then
there's an element that also requires a
certain amount of awareness or energy
and you got to step outside of that
unconscious state so
the thoughts that they're thinking are
slipping by their awareness unnoticed
because they're hardwired in their brain
because they've been saying i can't it's
too hard my life will never change it's
someone else's fault those thoughts have
consequences in the body
so then if a person then becomes
conscious
of those unconscious thoughts becomes
aware of how they speak and how they act
and they notice
how they're feeling they're no longer
the program they're the consciousness
outside the program and that's the first
step to change so
there are
when you when you're distracted by your
environment and you got your cell phone
and your tweeting and your
instagramming and facebook and whatever
people do you're distracted by that
feeling
but i now know that if you take a person
and you say okay close your eyes
sit in the in the silence of any
external stimulation remove the
environment sit your body down like an
animal body is the animal tell it to
stay i'm going to feed you
you can check your cell phone you can
shower you can have your coffee but when
i say
and so then here comes the challenge
right so and and then
if you say then you're not going to live
in the familiar future familiar past or
predictable future you're not going to
think about how long you've been
meditating what you got to do you you
labor
for that present moment
people think when they do this that
they're doing something wrong because
there's such discomfort that comes with
it
but they're in the unknown they're
actually doing it right people say i
think i'm meditating wrong i always say
oh no no no you're doing it right
because when you notice that your body
wants to get up and
check your cell phone or have a cup of
coffee and you become aware that it's on
autopilot and wants to do that and you
say
come on over here
and you return it back to the present
moment
you're executing a will now
that's greater than the program and if
the person
wants to just get angry while they're
sitting there there's an arousal and
they notice the body is amping up and
revving up and they settle it back down
now they're telling the body it's no
longer the mind that they're the mind
now we've researched this
and it's tedious
in the beginning at first because david
is fighting goliath
but if you keep practicing it just like
training an animal
sooner or later the body acquiesces
sooner or later the body is trained to a
new mind and when that happens
there's a liberation of energy the body
goes from particle to wave from matter
to energy and there goes that emotion
literally liberated from the body as
energy
so the person who has the strong emotion
to some circumstance in their life
and they're
working and lowering the volume of that
emotion the more they lower the volume
that emotion the more they're going to
take their attention off that person and
problem and they're going to take their
power back there's going to be a break
in their attention from that
circumstance and now they build their
own field and now there's energy to heal
now there's energy to create a new life
now there's energy for the mystical
moment because they've overcome their
old personality self so
i think you know it's not like thinking
positively that's not the message it's
it's overcoming
overcoming
overcoming overcoming until we become
somebody else and when that occurs and
the person starts thinking differently
and they start acting differently
and they start feeling differently
they're a new personality and yeah they
start seeing those synchronicities and
serendipities now
crossing that river of change
the creative process now gets exciting
because what thoughts do you want to
fire in wire in your brain what kind of
attention and intention
do you want to place so that that
becomes the loudest voice in your head
and if you keep practicing it the
hardware becomes a software program and
it'll say jay you can do anything jay
you live in no time and accomplish
everything jay
you're unlimited you just got to hang
with it on the other side of this is
greatness whatever you want to program
in there you get to program in there
want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carl michael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn how you
can reprogram your broke mindset
enjoy
rule number two believe in abundance i
had this belief that i did not have an
abundant amount of money and uh that i
was always in struggle and that came
from my parents bless them you know they
are beautiful
um but that that came from them you know
we can't afford it and all of those
things so i was brought up with that as
many of us are so the the one
one that i had the biggest thing to
overcome the belief the biggest thing to
overcome
was the belief in lack of money
and and i knew i needed to overcome that
for the secret to
sweep the world all the things i was
going to buy you know when the money
came in
um so i did all of these lists and i
imagined that i had those things already
um
and yeah and i wanted i remember it was
like i want a house on the ocean i
really went all out you know that was
just some list
um one of the things i remember is that
i'd always wanted a range for overall of
my life and that was just beyond
anything i could afford
and especially in australia like they
were crazy prices so but still i put it
on the list and i put all these things
on the list but you know interestingly
enough like i did that because that was
a way to turn money around
but when the secret got released i
didn't care about any of it because
and i didn't even care all that mattered
was that i had got it out into the world
and now it was in the world it could
never be taken away and that is what
mattered to me more than anything is
that that was going to get into people's
hands and so
um but still i have to tell you got all
the things on the list
you know it has amazing views out here
of the ocean um i ended up by getting a
range rover
um and so yeah but i did i did a lot of
practices rule number three place it in
your imagination with wayne dyer a basic
thing that neville taught me and a lot
of this is from the teachings of neville
uh neville goddard who died in the 1970s
he
he basically said that um all of us
have within us this
amazing capacity to manifest and attract
anything that we want into our life so
how we call it what what words that we
use we have to be able to say um you
know in the secret they say you get what
you want you know and what is missing
and what neville said and what has come
to me and what i got from the i am
discourses and what i get from the new
testament which i read before i did it
is that you you say
i will attract into my life what i am
not what i want and i am capable of
attracting all things that
that the source is capable of attracting
so
that's the difference it's like you get
what you are rather than what you want
so you want to become
you can't go around and ask these divine
beings you know angels whatever you want
to call them who are right here all the
time
you can't ask them to help me out you
have to you have to become like they are
that when you're when you become angelic
when you become a divine being yourself
when you are giving when you are serving
when you are in that place they will
come to you that's what happened to you
in india you then begin to see yourself
in everything that's what the daoda
chain teaches as well they call it your
original nature your original nature is
reverence for all of life gentleness
kindness and service towards others
that's lao tzu 500 years before the
birth of christ saying that's our
original nature yes reverence for all of
life gentleness kindness service towards
other giving offering serving and when
you get to that place where you no
longer have any judgment within you
towards any of god's children that means
no condemnation no criticism no judgment
towards anyone even the osama bin laden
if enough of us get on that's just what
my mission is is just to teach people
that you are love you are divine put
that into your imagination i am i am
well i am happy i am content i am
fulfilled even if your senses tell you
that you're depressed one of your people
that called me when we did a
pre-interview on here said well if i if
i'm feeling depressed i'm supposed to
fool myself and say i am feeling well
even you can choose another thought
that's what i have absolutely and it's
like you don't say i am depressed
because if you say i am depressed you
connect with depression and the
universal source god whatever you want
to call it will align in such a way to
offer you whatever it is
yeah here's some more depression i am
unhappy i am depressed i am so by
placing into your imagination what you
want and assuming the feeling of that
wish is already fulfilled you go through
your life feeling that when enough of us
do that we will we will transform this
planet i'm telling you it can be done
rule number four change your thinking
with louise hay you will never find
working a pleasure if you hate your job
or you can't stand your boss
what a terrible affirmation that is
it will be impossible for you to ever
attract a great job with that belief
system
if you want to enjoy your time at work
then you must change your thinking
i'm a great believer in blessing with
love every person place and thing at the
workplace
begin with your current job
affirm that this job is merely a
stepping stone to far greater positions
you are in your current job because of
the things you believed in the past you
drew it to you by your thinking
perhaps you learned your attitude
towards work from your parents
no matter you can change your thinking
now so bless with love your boss
your co-workers the location the
building the stairs or elevators the
rooms the furniture and each and every
customer
this creates a loving mental atmosphere
within you and the whole office will
respond to it
i have never understood the reasoning
behind putting down or berating others
at work
if you are an owner a manager or a
supervisor how can you possibly expect
to get the best work from others if they
are frightened or resentful
we all want to be appreciated
acknowledged and encouraged
if you support your employees and give
them respect then they will give you the
best work they can
now please don't believe that it is hard
to get a job that may be true for many
but it does not have to be true for you
you only need one job and your
consciousness will open the pathway for
you
don't have faith in fear
when you hear of negative trends in
business or in the economy immediately
affirm
that may be true for some but it is not
true for me i always prosper no matter
where i am or what is going on
people often ask me for the affirmations
to make their relationships at work be
smoother
in fact for many people this is a really
big issue in their lives
i am deeply aware that whatever i give
out comes back to me multiplied and this
is true everywhere including at work
in the workplace it is important to know
that every employee and employer has
been attracted by the action of love for
its his and her divine right place here
and now at this point in time and space
divine harmony permeates us all and we
can all flow together in the workplace
in a most productive and joyous way
there aren't any problems that don't
have solutions there aren't any
questions without answers
choose to go beyond the problem to seek
the divine right action solution to any
discord that may seem to appear
be willing to learn from any discord or
confusion as it comes up
it's important to release all blame and
turn within to seek the truth
and be willing to release whatever
pattern may be in your consciousness
that has contributed to the situation
know that you are successful in all that
you do
you're inspired and productive
you serve others willingly and gladly
divine harmony reigns supreme within and
around you and within and around each
and every person in your workplace
when you know and declare that it's
possible to successfully operate in the
workplace according to divine principles
then divine love brings to you those who
can be helped by that which you so
lovingly do
now if you like your job but feel you're
not getting paid enough then bless your
current salary with love
expressing gratitude for what you do
have enables it to grow
and absolutely no more bitching about
the job or co-workers
your consciousness put you where you are
now your changing consciousness can lift
you to a better position
you can do it
during your work day there are a number
of things you can do to release tension
here are a few ideas
one
before you go to work every day do this
simple exercise just sit comfortably and
concentrate on your breath
whenever you notice thoughts coming in
gently bring your awareness back to your
breath
give yourself at least 10 or 15 minutes
to dwell in the silence each day there
is nothing difficult or tricky to this
and it's worth taking the time
two
write or type this affirmation and put
it where you can see it at work
my job is a peaceful haven
i bless my job with love
i put love in every corner and my job
lovingly responds with warmth and
comfort
i am at peace
when you start to think about your boss
say this affirmation to yourself
i only give out that which i wish to
receive
my love and acceptance of others is
mirrored to me in every way
refuse to be limited in any way by human
mind thinking
your life can be filled with love and
joy because your work is a divine idea
remember to say to yourself every day
before going to work
no matter where i am there is only
infinite good infinite wisdom infinite
harmony and love
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five activate your
imagination bob proctor if you look at
this for a moment
i think that neville put it very well he
said
you're only limited
by weakness of attention
and poverty of imagination
i want you to think about that for a
moment
really give that some thought
you're only limited by weakness of
attention
you know i have quoted
dr warner von braun on numerous
occasions
when john kennedy when he was the
president of the united states asked the
good doctor the
father of the space program greatest
scientist
you know what it would take to build a
rocket that'll carry a person on the
moon and bring him back safely to earth
he answered him in five words he said
the will to do it
now
will is a mental faculty your perception
the will reason imagination memory and
intuition
these are all our higher faculties this
is what makes us who we actually are
this what separates us from all the rest
of the animal kingdom
and
neville's saying
you're only limited by weakness of
attention
warner von braun was telling president
kennedy
all you need is to give it your full
attention
the will to do it
see the will gives us the ability to
concentrate
i don't know what you want
but i do know this
if you can think it
and you can let yourself get emotionally
involved with it
and you stay focused on it
you can have it
now that's a very basic concept
but it's not the easiest thing for most
people to do
but the more you study it the better
you're going to get at it
but i love this you're only limited by
weakness of attention
and poverty of imagination
you've got to activate your imagination
a lot of people just use their
imagination for gosh i hope this doesn't
happen i hope that doesn't happen
they're letting it go in the wrong
direction
our imagination is the most marvelous
he'll in in think and grow rich hill
said the imagination is the most
marvelous miraculous
inconceivably powerful force that the
world's ever known
it's
it'll create anything for you it'll take
you anywhere
your imagination will take you anywhere
and it'll give you anything you want
that's a beautiful thing to know rule
number six pay the price with tom bilyeu
this is the central mantra of my life
it doesn't matter who you are today
it really doesn't so if you feel like
you're incapable of something maybe you
are today
but just because you're incapable of
something today doesn't mean that you're
not capable
of learning that thing so it's not about
who you are today
it's about who you want to become
and the price you're willing to pay to
get there
and i promise you
the day that you're willing to pay any
price
you'll achieve what you want to achieve
rule number seven believe with les brown
i want you to look at something right
now think of some major goal you want or
maybe it's one you're already working on
and you have experienced a lot of
setbacks a lot of defeats
you've experienced a lot of
disappointment maybe you've already
given up
and maybe you just need a little fire a
little encouragement to get back in the
game again here's what i want you to
look at
they're winners
and they're losers
and there are people who have not
discovered how to win
and all they need is some coaching
all they need is some help and
assistance just a little support
all they need is some insight or
different strategy or plan of action to
make some adjustments
that will open up the key to a whole new
future for them that will give them
access to the unlimited power that they
have within themselves that's all that
they need
so what i want you to do is think about
something you want for you
that's real for you
that's important for you that will give
your life some special meaning and power
and i don't even want you to say i can
do that
i don't want you to assume that
see five years ago when i started out in
this area
i would not have been able to make the
mental leap that i would be up to where
i am right now
i don't want you to begin to just psych
yourself out
no no i want you to be able to say
something to yourself that will enable
you to maintain a level of integrity
with yourself that when you say this
even when you face tremendous setbacks
it it will be a benchmark to keep you in
the game to keep you
moving forward and experimenting and
readjusting your strategy and your plan
of action continuously looking for ways
to win
so what is that something
when you got an idea you want to move on
you might not have the money you might
not have the education
you might not have the support of the
resources you need what is that
something
that can keep us going that will enable
us to act on our dream what's one of
those keys
that will begin to help us to discover
the secrets to our dream here's what i
want you to repeat after me please with
power and conviction say it's possible
that's all i want you to do when you
look at your dream
you say to yourself every day
it's possible
you say that every day to yourself it's
possible
because what does that do see
it begins to change your belief system
see the way in which we operate ladies
and gentlemen
it's a manifestation of what we believe
what's possible for us
whatever you've done up to this point
all that it really is
is a duplication it's a reproduction of
what you believe subconsciously that you
deserve and what's possible for your
life before april 1954
the common belief the universal belief
because it had been tried
again and again and again and people
have failed
the belief was that man was not
physically capable
of breaking the four-minute barrier that
he could not run a mile
in less than four minutes that was the
belief
on the planet it had never been done
but here's what happened ladies and
gentlemen
roger bannister came along
and he broke the four-minute barrier
now here's what's significant about that
since that time
up to this day
over 20
000 people have done it including high
school kids
what changed
20 000 people what changed here's what
happened when they got on the track they
knew it had been done
and because they knew it had been done
there was a new belief about this
barrier about this goal that was
unreachable
and those 20 000 people got in a race
believing
knowing in their heart that someone had
done it that it's possible that they
could do it
and i'm saying that if you know anybody
that had some goal some dream something
they wanted to
do and they did it the nice thing that
you know in your heart that if someone
has done it then you can do it it's
possible
and that if someone can make that dream
become a reality that it's it's possible
that you can make your dream become
reality and rule number eight the last
one before some very special bonus clips
is reprogram yourself with bruce lipton
bill is a friend like you've had in your
past hi tanya what a pretty kitty cat
you have a friend that you've been very
close to
like bill you know his behavior very
very well hey
jenny hi
see you later
and so not only do you know your
friend's behavior but in this particular
case you know your friend's parent so
bill
you find out is just like his parents
sometimes
i'm so stupid i can't do anything right
bill is a happy-go-lucky guy most of the
time but every now and then he stumbles
[Music]
and when he does so he gets very upset
oh i'm so stupid i can't do anything
right
[Music]
and the behavior express is not the
behavior that we know of built
oh okay
hi alex when you see bill behaving like
his father it excites you and you can't
wait to tell bill and you say
hey bill you're just like your dad
then you back away from bill i i'm not
like my dad i i'm nothing like my dad
how could you say i'm like my dad i'm
not i'm not my dad no
i'm not like him and bill gets so upset
and screams out how how can you compare
me to my father i am nothing like my
father
we've all seen that
we all laughed over it
but it has a very profound story and the
story is simply this we have been
programmed during our development by our
parents and in that process we acquire
their behaviors and the unfortunate part
about this is that these behaviors are
in our subconscious mind and we don't
see them
what's interesting
bill gets all excited and upset that you
compare him to his father and guess what
he is just like his father but there's a
profound point to this story everyone
else can see that bill looks like his
father it's only bill who doesn't see
this well this is more than just an
interesting story because the profound
point is bill's behavior is not exactly
what bill thinks it is every now and
then he comes out with his father's less
than good behavior and i say well why is
this relevant
well
because another profound point of this
story
we
are all bill
meaning
every day just like bill
we are playing programs and just like
bill we can't see them and i say why is
this relevant
because if we're playing subconscious
programs that we can't see then by
definition we are sabotaging our lives
and yet we can see we are the ones that
are sabotaging it so when things don't
go right we generally look up and say oh
it's not in my fate to have something
wonderful oh it's not in the cards oh
the universe is not supporting me and we
start to see ourselves as victims of
life out of control and we start blaming
everything and everyone around us for
the failures that we are experiencing
and yet the most important insight is
this
the problem isn't on the outside the
problem as we just revealed with bill is
on the inside all of us like bill have
programs that we can't see when we play
them about 70 of the programs we
downloaded by a7 are negative
disempowering and self-sabotaging and
yet their subconscious programs the
significant point is
subconscious programs means programs
below the level of consciousness
so all of us like bill during the day
start playing programs from the
background and training that we receive
from our own parents
significance
if life isn't going well it's not the
universe that is preventing you from
having what you wish
it's your own developmental programming
and why this is so important is because
if we can see where we're struggling in
life we can also recognize this is where
an invisible program in our subconscious
is taking us off of our track
the significance is simply this
anything in your life that you desire
but you have to work hard for struggle
over sweat over put a lot of effort into
it a big question why are you working so
hard to get to that destination
the big answer
is because unconsciously you are playing
programs that you downloaded from your
family and your community
that are sabotaging you and just like
bill you're playing these programs and
you can't see them
all you see is the result of a negative
program you do not see
how much you are creating that program
so it's important for us to step back at
this time and recognize
when we struggle to obtain our wishes
and desires
it's not an issue from outside control
it's an issue of inside programming and
once you know this
we are free to change that programming
and when we change that programming we
become empowered because with new
programs we can program success
happiness health and love
your energy dictates your results think
about it when you have felt
positive motivated energized ready to go
courageous bold you show up differently
right you show up differently than when
you're feeling depressed that it's not
going to work out
the negative self-talk someone like you
can't do it you're not getting any
momentum you're not getting the results
like think about your own mental state
when you are
trying to accomplish a goal
and the difference between when you have
positive energy versus negative energy
it has nothing to do with your skills
has nothing to do with your potential it
has everything to do with how you're
feeling right now
right it's why i say that lack of belief
is the world's number one problem
you don't believe in yourself enough you
don't have the right energy level and so
you don't go off and create even though
you've got it inside you to do it and
you've got the heart and the mission and
the care and the love and you want to do
it
so it's all about changing your energy
states
i think there's a misconception that
people who are high achievers wake up
and just feel energized and motivated
ready to go right today i did not wake
up and say yes come on
[Music]
let's go take on the day i'm so excited
right that's how i woke up today i woke
up it was dark outside it's snowing as
you can you can tell here right it's
snowing look at look at what look at
what nina's driving through
stay safe nina
both of our safety depends on it
she's driving through the snow storm
it's dark outside
and i wake up and and the difference is
i don't i don't put my feet on the
ground to get all jazzed up and start
yelling about what a great day it's
gonna be i wake up but i'm tired and
like why is it so dark outside
why we have this snowstorm uh you know
i'm thinking about the call i had
yesterday with brendon burchard on zoom
and he's showing me his
tropical
puerto rican beach backdrop and i got
canadian snow happening here right now
the difference is
the people who you admire who have the
success who are the high achievers they
don't wake up like there's a superhuman
and extra motivated
they're just like you the difference is
they have the habits and the routines
where they demand the energy from
themselves they create the energy for
themselves and so there's there's two
things that i want you to start thinking
about how do you do it right like okay
great evan how do i do it how do i
actually change my energy how do i get
it so that i am feeling powerful bold
motivated confident excited on a daily
basis because it is possible and because
you know how great you feel and you know
the results that you get when you're
feeling that way
so two things that i want you to keep in
mind the first one is
having
something in your morning routine that
demands that from you so for me music is
the fastest way to change my state music
i have a playlist called the believe
playlist
it's hashtag believe all caps on my main
channel you can go find it that's the
music i listen to every day that may not
be the thing that gets you fired up
but it is for me
music is the fastest way to change your
state because there are some songs that
when they come on when you hear them
it just makes you want to move you might
get up and dance you might just be
nodding your head you might be tapping
your foot but there are some songs that
come on that make you want to move it
can't just be the same song every day
because then you're going to get sick of
it and bored of it but you make a
playlist of the different music that
when it comes on
it forces you to shift your state
we often put on the music for how we
currently feel
so when you're sad and low and depressed
or upset you put on music that makes you
feel
reinforced and you're sad and low and
depressed and upset states
when you're sad and low you don't put on
music to make you feel better you put on
music to keep you where you are that's
the problem that that then what it keeps
you where you are
right when you put on the music for how
you currently feel it keeps you where
you are where what you want to do is use
music to shift your state so when you're
feeling not so motivated when you're
feeling tired when you're feeling low
you put on music that gets you up and
what's going to happen you're going to
feel a little bit more up so putting
that as a part of your daily routine
daily daily daily daily daily daily
daily daily daily daily daily daily
routine it matters it makes a difference
if you if you started your day with
music that would make you feel
energized pumped up motivated ready to
go if you started your day with that
your day will look different your days
will look different your weeks will look
different your months will look
different and the the things that you
accomplish will look dramatically
different okay so that's a daily basis i
need you to shift your morning routine
to incorporate something like that just
try it try for a week and see how you
feel it'll make a difference i promise
step number two is
reacting to the moment so that's what we
do in step number one we do on a daily
basis in the morning step number two is
when we have something that
we come across that
makes us feel
less confident that makes us feel scared
that is a big opportunity that makes us
question ourselves doubt ourselves when
you look at your calendar you look at
your emails you look at the results and
you see that you're not where you want
to be the tendency is to beat ourselves
up the tendency is to play scared the
tendency is to act small the tendency is
to procrastinate and go do something
else
right you know i've been there you've
been there maybe you are there right now
you know what i'm talking about
energy
is now the reason why we're staying
where we are so how do we shift our
energy
in those moments
one remind yourself that you do
difficult things
you do difficult things
that if it's hard if it's scary that
it's difficult you're gonna do it you're
gonna do it you're gonna show up you're
gonna do it because you do difficult
things
it cuts the brain out of the equation
because now it's time to show yourself
what you can do
instead of overthinking over
procrastinating
and being overly scared i want to
explain something to you
that not many people really understand i
want to talk about the law of attraction
do you know that the law of attraction
is always working it's like the law of
gravity if i let this go it's going to
go down it's never going to go back up
it's going to go down that is the law of
gravity anything heavier than earth is
attracted towards the center of the
world well the law of attraction is
always working
now how does it work
well
i use a diagram to explain the mind now
let this circle represent your mind
and let this little circle here
represent your body
now i want you to think of this for a
moment
your body is a molecular structure this
is a massive energy and a very high
speed of vibration
if you looked at your body through a
microscope you'd see that energy dancing
right before your eyes and here's
something that'll keep you thinking for
the next 20 years when you move out of
it the body does not stop moving if you
go to a funeral parlor and pick up the
remains and look at it you will see it
moving and if it wasn't moving how would
it ever change the dust
you move into your body and you will
move up
and it's how you use your mind that's
going to dictate the vibration you're in
now stay with me
you have an imaginary line right across
here
and that separates the conscious mind
from the subconscious mind
now this subconscious mind has been
programmed
when you were a little baby this is the
way it was go just like this
subconscious mind wide open and
everything that was going on around it
went right in there
and all the energy that went in there
when you were just a little baby form
something called a paradigm
now a paradigm
is information it's a multitude of
habits you are the product of your
environment but prior to that you are
the product of a genetic strain that
goes back for generations now i'm going
to say that the paradigm is x type
energy
now you've got the ability here on a
conscious level to think
and you can think anything you want to
think
and as you think you build ideas
there's a power that's flowing into your
consciousness it never stops it flows to
and through you you can actually
photograph this power leaving you it
flows to and through you
now as it flows in you will start
thinking and you'll probably think x
type thoughts
therefore you're going to be in an x
type vibration
and that will produce
x type results now it's the results you
want to change
and to change the results you're going
to have to change what you attract
you see the thoughts that you think
control the vibration that you're in
vibration is nothing but an idea it's a
law of the universe everything vibrates
nothing rests we live in a notion of
motion
and it's the thoughts that you're
thinking that you impress upon your
subconscious mind that control the
vibration the body's in and that
dictates how you act but it also
dictates what you attract
you attract energy that's in harmony
with you you attract people that are in
harmony with you you see everything
operates on frequencies there's an
infinite number of frequencies but you
and i operate on a frequency just like a
radio station does and the only music
you can attract is the music that is
tuned in to the vibration you're in
now it's the paradigm that has been
controlling the vibration you can change
your thinking
but that doesn't do anything you've got
to change the paradigm
and if you don't change the paradigm
nothing happens
now
talking about paradigms is another
subject we'll do that at another time
but it's the thoughts that you think
that control the vibration you're in and
that dictates what you attract so if you
keep attracting what you don't want
understand this
it's the paradigm that's causing the
problem you can think a y type thought
which is totally different than the x
type conditioning it isn't going to go
anywhere
because when you go to get emotionally
involved and this is the emotional mind
when you go to get emotionally involved
with that white tape time the paradigm
will kick it out you know why it's so
uncomfortable
that's stepping out of the box that's
doing things different and we don't like
to do things different because it causes
a lot of discomfort
but understand this the paradigm and the
thinking control the vibration you're in
and the vibration is going to dictate
what you attract
people that are in a poverty
consciousness will continue to attract
lack and limitation it has nothing to do
with this what's going on here this is
your educated mind and you can gather
all kinds of information have you ever
wondered why some people have such an
educated mind they have degrees coming
right off the end of their business card
but it doesn't show up in the results
why
paradigm
the law of attraction
you've got to change this
you've got to change the vibration
you're in and your whole world changes
listen in 1961 a man gave me this book
and he said do exactly what i tell you
he was giving me y type ideas it caused
an enormous amount of discomfort but i
did exactly what he said and you know
something
my income went from 4 000 to 175 000 in
a year and then i took it over a million
it took me nine and a half years to
figure out what happened
this is what i'm showing you watch this
over and over and over again there's a
number of lessons in here when the
paradigms change your life changes
it's a beautiful concept it's an
absolutely phenomenal concept
now you know why you're getting the
results you're getting it has nothing to
do with your intellect your intellect
you can figure out how to do things that
doesn't mean you're going to do them
you'll hear people say i believe that
but their behavior would indicate
they've never even heard of it why
we believe something on a conscious
level on a subconscious level the
paradigm believes something else
there's a word called praxis praxis is
the integration of belief with behavior
we've got to take the beliefs that we
have consciously that we determine by
thinking
and plant them in the place of the old
belief see i used to believe that i
couldn't do anything better than i was
doing
i felt fortunate that i was on the fire
department
the idea of building a company that
operated all around the world furthest
thing from my mind
but you know something as i changed my
paradigm my whole world changed
that's what we do that's what it's all
about
you've got to change your paradigm if
you want to change your life now you can
study all you want if you don't gain an
understanding how to alter that program
and that's what the paradigm is it's a
program it's a multitude of concepts
that are fixed in your subconscious mind
that literally control your behavior
it's a beautiful concept
to understand
it's a terrible one if you don't
understand it because it literally
controls your life why do you think most
people go right through their life and
keep getting the same results year after
year after year
well
it's just the way it is and they don't
know we should be taught this in school
but we're not
how is the paradigm formed through the
repetition of information how's the
paradigm change repetition of
information
now let's suppose you're having a
difficult time with money
you find that you've got more going out
than coming in
you've got to change your concept about
money how do you do that through the
repetition of an idea that's where
affirmations comes in i'll give you one
i've been using for years
i am so happy and grateful now that
money comes to me in increasing
quantities through multiple sources on a
continuous basis i am so happy and
grateful now that money comes to me in
increasing quantities through multiple
sources on a continuous basis
you don't just say that once or twice
you've got to repeat that maybe a
thousand times a day every day for maybe
90 days and you'll start to change your
whole concept about money wealthy people
all have multiple sources of income
now i'm going to tell you what happened
to me
i drove around with a battery operated
record player
and a long playing record
and i played it over and over again
every day for probably a couple of years
this was so totally illogical it was
behavior everybody thought i was losing
it and i'm reading the same book every
day think and grow rich as a matter of
fact i'm still reading the same book
and it was the repetition
of earl nightingale's information
and the book that changed the paradigm i
didn't know what i was doing i didn't
understand what i was doing but i did it
do you know i had a man come up to me
in the waldorf hotel in new york the
waldorf astoria
at the end of a three-day program and he
said bob i really want to thank you for
what you've just given to me he said for
the first time in my life i've
understood how i accomplished what i did
i said what did you do he said i won the
gold medal in the decathlon in the
olympics in melbourne australia in
1957
that's right
milt campbell and he said i never
understood how he did it he said the
next time you run a seminar i want to
bring my boys and he did milt and i
became great friends in fact milt has a
key to our house he can come stay there
any time he wants i live in toronto he's
in new jersey
but here was the top athlete the world a
very best athlete in the world he didn't
understand how he got there
most people that are very accomplished
cannot tell you why they are that's why
they are they've rewritten the program
they changed the paradigm they might not
have understood how they did it but they
did it
that's what our company is all about we
teach people how to change paradigms i
want to thank you for watching this
but i'm going to ask you to share it
with other people
share it with them say come and watch
this
start a rapport build a rapport with
people you know
it's a great way to live
and this is great information to
understand i had to start figuring out
how to how to walk in the darkness
because that's kind of what it's like
what darkness what do you mean like
meaning when you're caught in this
psycho-cybernetic loop can you define
psycho-cybernetics yeah so
um it's this idea that um what you
believe
uh will dictate your thoughts on a
moment-by-moment basis so if you believe
that you know money is hard to make as a
simple example you're not going to have
ideas or thoughts around money that
would be
lending to making it easily right
uh and so so what you believe dictates
what you think you can't get like an
apple from an orange tree and what you
think you then experience is an emotion
right and then that emotion then
dictates what actions you do or do not
take and they're always aligned right
your beliefs dictate your thoughts
dictate your emotions dictate your
actions which produce your results and
your results when you look at them then
just reinforce the original belief
and so we're caught in that construct
right but the linchpin is the belief
system so the question is how do i
actually change what i believe if my
beliefs really do dictate my destiny
right which is i'm not the only person
suggesting that the question becomes how
do i change my beliefs and in that is is
an inherent challenge because by
definition beliefs are that which are
true
right for us
um and so then then the question is how
do we break out of this
my way of breaking out of it was at one
point to understand and i'll start to
kind of walk you through the structure
of it
to understand that there were only two
states of emotional beingness that i
could be in at any given point in time
i would either be in a powerful state of
being states like joy curiosity
excitement calm peace
passion or i would be in a primal state
of being boredom anger frustration
some form of fear
i'm always in one of those two states
and i'm never in two states at one time
those map beautifully to the sympathetic
nervous system and the parasympathetic
nervous system right so at any moment
we're either in fight or flight or we're
in rest and relaxation
through my journey what i realized was
the only cause of that switch to be
flipped was my own thinking the meaning
that i was giving the experience the
experience itself wasn't dictating
whether i was in a primal state or a
powerful state whether i was in
sympathetic fight or flight or
parasympathetic rest and rest and
restoration or relaxation it was the
meaning i was giving the experience and
so that meant that all of my personal
suffering was within my own control
i needed to start controlling the
meaning i was giving the experiences of
life
as we started doing this work early i
didn't see this initially in the work
that i was doing with myself but as we
started building a team of coaches and
as the coaches were coaching people what
we consistently saw was that the quality
of the thinking
that was causing people to move into a
primal state which was really the only
problem because when you're in a
powerful state you're connected to
creativity to inspiration to vitality to
energy health automatically operates
everything that we want is in a powerful
state of being when you're in a primal
state you don't have access to any of
that so when entrepreneurs say to me for
example what's the number one thing you
would suggest to grow my business i
would say notice by moment by moment
what state of being you're in and use
whatever tools or technologies you have
access to to move back into a powerful
state that's where things just unfold
and i'm not saying you don't have to
take consistent action and work your ass
off to create success but you do it from
a powerful state it's very hard to do it
from a primal state
what we were seeing consistently was
that the quality of thinking that was
causing people to move into a primal
state when we really looked at it worked
with them around it was that 100 of the
time it was untrue
the only thing they were thinking they
were thinking was untrue i'm not good
enough i'm not smart enough i'm not good
enough i'm not smart enough there's not
enough time now we can start to talk
about like the larger metaphysical
philosophy behind all of this right uh
but i'll give you a prime example i was
working uh
personally coaching a 29 year old
egyptian muslim young man super
successful had his first multi-million
dollar business at 19 years old was
large running one of the largest
companies in this category at 29 years
old and i've been coaching him and he
was out one night in south beach with a
bunch of movers and shakers
and um vice president of the sports team
number one dj fashion designers whatever
it was he called me the next day and he
said listen i moved into a primal state
last night and i couldn't get out of it
so i need you to coach me on it because
i know his his vision for his life now
the most important thing for him is to
operate from a powerful state of being
i said okay so
what happened he said well i was there
and i noticed that i started having
anxiety so i know i moved into a primal
state i said what'd you do next he said
i took a look at the thinking that was
causing it i said what did you find he
said i was thinking that i don't belong
here
i was like okay got it so then what did
you do and what we teach we teach a
couple of things but what we teach at
the highest level of this work is that
you're able to actually see the thinking
that's not true
is not true
and that's different than
a lot of the other
modalities i tried to use
to evolve
you can change your state
you can reframe something you can come
up with a better story
they're amazing tools out there like
breathwork plant tech i mean there's a
bunch of stuff out there which we can
get into right heck yeah that's nice
there's a bunch of stuff out there right
but i'm we're very focused on the
personal technology not the third party
tools right but i've explored a lot of
them
so
what we believe is the fastest way for
you to eradicate a limiting belief is to
actually see the limiting belief as
untrue and the moment that happens
there's a reorganization in your brain
like you can't unsee it once you see the
lie is a lie
right there's a huge shift it reorients
you to the experiences of your life it
reorients you to you to money to
relationships so i said to him so what
happened when you saw
that you were thinking i don't belong
here and he says it seemed true
he goes now i knew it wasn't because he
bought in to what we teach
and i said okay great so i'll coach you
on it you know with coaching you have a
lot of leverage and you don't always
have to use a leverage i'm going to give
you an example of
but i knew he was a spiritual
his faith was very important to him so i
said let me ask you a question you
believe in god don't you he said yes i
said the omnipotent omniscient kind of
all-knowing type of god he goes
absolutely and i said then how did your
god put you in the wrong place on friday
night where you actually don't belong
and there was a pause
and i heard him on the other end of the
line and he goes oh my god and i said
what is it he goes
i belong everywhere i am
that's a fundamental reorientation to
the experiences of your life
and what i believe is that's the deepest
most permanent fastest way to actually
move through
the crazy unreality that we've created
for ourselves as a result of adopting a
bunch of other crazy people's beliefs
when we were kids right to start
reconnecting with what's really true
and so in that moment of seeing that you
actually believe everywhere belong
everywhere that you are you move back
into a powerful state and now you're
moving forward with your life in a
powerful way tantra means the technology
technology means
when those times when we did not have
any external instruments of technology
we realized the highest grade of
technologies here
and to exercise this
in many different ways
now
if we want to see outside the door
we need a periscope
now somebody found a way to look beyond
without a periscope
using your mind
beyond the realm of your body right now
mind is functioning within the realm of
your body you want to use it there
it is possible to do that it's not not
possible
it's just that
all kinds of wild and observed things
are believed if you trim those things
in many ways
or unknowingly many of you are using
this
you create what you want in the world
when you really want it
in a way it's simply your focus which
makes those things happen
maybe it is not as
tangible as uh it's in a cinema
but
every one of you to some extent you're
doing isn't it
how effectively do you do it
depends on uh
there are many things if i say
things that happen around me
they're too fairy talish
i wouldn't believe such nonsense if
anybody told me so i won't tell you
because i don't want you to believe or
disbelieve those things but every day
people around me witness things which
they think is nothing short of a miracle
but there's no miracle
life is a big miracle
are you a part of it or are you out of
it that's a big question question is are
you consciously in it or are you out of
it that's a big question
if you're in it
you're see if you use any thought
this is uh well he was asking how do we
do it in the beginning
suppose you generate a thought
have you noticed this suppose you
generate a thought
and then you invest your emotion in this
thought suddenly this thought becomes
boom
huh
yes or no
right now i generate a thought oh she's
such a wonderful person
but now i invest my emotion into the
thought now suddenly
you are not just another person to me
you are something else to me
is it reality or no
just because you invested your emotion
into your thought
now there is a next thing
if you invest your life energies into it
consciously
suddenly this will become something else
altogether
suddenly you become like
life is a play
is no more a struggle
because
miracles are always happening you put a
little seed it becomes a tree he eats a
noodle he becomes a man
i'm saying this is happening to
it's happening all the time just see you
put filth into the root just see it
becomes fragrance
is it is this not miracles and miracles
all over the place the question is only
are you consciously a part of this
miraculous creation or are you
stuck in your own logic and outside this
miracle
that's all the big differences many
people come to me and say i want to be a
millionaire i i and there's a great song
about i'm going to be a millionaire and
they read things like the secret which
says if you want to be a millionaire
just just wish it and it will happen
and that's not quite enough i've worked
with many many many millionaires and i
became on myself quite a long time ago
now never having possibly thought that
could ever happen when i was at school i
was going to be a nanny that's how much
i thought i could earn in my lifetime
that's what i thought i was meant to be
but then i worked with so many
multi-millionaires and billionaires and
i really understand
how to attract money how to attract
wealth i'm going to take you through
today
why you haven't yet become a millionaire
there's several things that will stop
you here's the number one
you don't believe you are worth it you
may want money you may long for money
but if you have an inner belief that
says i'm not worth it not only wouldn't
you attract that money if you did you
would get rid of all of it so if you
wish to become a millionaire you must
decide you're worth it the more
reasons you can decide you're worth it
the more you'll have that motivation
that fire that drive to go out
and make a lot of money the second thing
that will make you become and stay a
millionaire
is working out how much good you will do
with the millions that you make you see
bill gates what an amazing guy he says
that in 20 years
malaria won't exist because he is using
his money
to wipe out malaria that's an
extraordinary thing and he deserves all
the wealth he has for that reason alone
if you can think of something that you
could do or
the people you would help an impact by
becoming a millionaire the more reasons
you can come up with the more people you
can help the more reasons you will have
to become and stay a millionaire and
here's the third thing and this is so
important many people think well i'm
just going to float around and manifest
millions i'm just going to sit at home
on my sofa and manifest millions if you
want a job you go out and look for a job
if you want a new home you go out and
visit new homes you want a partner you
better go out and put yourself in front
of people
and if you want to make and keep
millions
you need to decide what are you going to
do
to make those millions what gift or
talent do you have that you can monetize
you may say i don't have anything but
that's not true
if you really take a while you can find
a gift a unique skill set you have that
you could monetize you see some of the
smartest people in the world they don't
invent a product they take an existing
product like james dice and he took a
hair dryer
he took a fan heater he took a vacuum
cleaner he took a hand dryer and he made
them better
and many many people take an existing
product to make it better and become a
millionaire that way
it's not about shall i invent something
i don't have an inventive mind i'm not
creative
it's about an idea you may come up with
a new product you may take someone
else's product for instance shapewear
wasn't new when spanx came on the market
and became a
multi-multi-million dollar company they
didn't invent a new product well they
sort of did they took an existing
product they made it so much better
and you can do that too
but the biggest blocks i see with
budding millionaires are these things
one is
i'm going to be a millionaire i'm going
to be a millionaire and they just try
and imagine in the future and the thing
about the mind is the human mind doesn't
future pace very well
one of the reasons depressed people
can't snap out of it is because they
can't future pace and by the way if this
is making sense to you please like
please share please subscribe to my
channel show to other people who also
want to make money why wouldn't you want
to make money you can do great things
for others when you make money but they
don't know how
they've been deluded by these
manifestation rooms sit at home and chan
on shanti
and money will fall from the heavens we
all know
that's not true
so if you want money you must be able to
visualize but it must be now
you must be able to think of
how you're going to what could you
possibly do to make money
remember that woman who changed the face
of a floor mop they made a movie about
her and she became a millionaire and she
was a housewife but one day she was
mopping her floor you know this is not
really a good mark she recreated and
reinvented a floor mop and
has made millions that way
but here's another big block you have to
work hard many people think well i just
manifest i just sit at home
the best plan in the world will not work
if you don't work
so people get this really weird belief
that people who make millions don't work
they just manifest it falls from the
heavens they float around doing a little
stuff here and there and that's not true
i work with millionaires and
billionaires and they do work hard they
work long
and they work hard on their way to
success they work a lot when they get
success
of course they can take time out but you
see when you do what you love and love
what you do it never really feels like
work i love what i do
i do what i love often say i feel like
i've never worked a day in my life
because i love what i do but really
i have worked out when i've written
books i've been writing for 12 hours a
day meeting deadlines i travel all over
the world through time zones giving
talks and sometimes that's tiring i plan
out my schools and i'm there teaching
but i love it so much it doesn't feel
like work but if you believe you can be
a millionaire
and not have to change anything or do
anything or work hard you will probably
never be a millionaire
you have to work hard you have to apply
yourself the best plan will not work if
you don't you have to have phenomenal
extraordinary self-belief
and finally you have to put yourself
around other people who've made money
ask them what did you do
what happened to you you see i met wayne
dyer many years ago and he said somebody
always remembered do not die with your
music still inside and i thought wow
i'm one of the best therapists in the
world and i can't die with my therapy i
mean i need to create a course make a
school teacher to other people i was so
glad i listened to him
and i've listened to many people who say
the same thing i didn't go to university
i didn't have a child background i
wasn't born into money but i had a dream
a vision and i
married that vision to very hard work i
kept going
please don't think successfully will
never get rejected they do but they
bounce back they come back they have
unshakable
unwavering confidence they have drive
and determination
so take a few minutes and just get a
little notebook or on your phone write
out all the reasons why you would like
to be a millionaire
all the good things you could do if you
were a millionaire the people you could
help
and then decide
what industry you could go into you're
going to invent something create
something
and some of the smartest people create
things entirely by mistake
look at what other millionaires have
done read some books written by
millionaires there are many
read richard branson reed felix dennis
look at some stories of millionaires and
decide if they can do it i can do it
this is a template
and i'm going to follow that template
and if you have the belief the vision
the work ethic the drive
and the confidence you will become a
millionaire life is a series of changes
those of us who are rigid and inflexible
in our thinking often snap when the
winds of change blow
but those of us who are like willow
trees
bend easily and adapt to the new changes
if we refuse to change then life passes
us by and we get left behind
just as a flexible body is more
comfortable to be in
so is a flexible mind more comfortable
to live in
i am open to the new and changing
every moment presents a wonderful new
opportunity to become more of who i am
i flow with life easily
and effortlessly
[Music]
i now go beyond other people's fears and
limitations
i am not my mother's fears and
limitations nor am i my father's fears
and limitations i'm not even my own
fears and limitations these are only
false thoughts that have been hanging
around in my mind
i can erase them as easily as i can
clean a dirty window when the window of
my mind is clean i can see clearly the
negative thoughts for what they are and
i can choose to eliminate them
it is my mind that creates my
experiences i am unlimited in my own
ability to create the good in my life
life mirrors my every thought
as i keep my thoughts positive life
brings me only good experiences
there is plenty for everyone including
me
there is so much food on this planet
that we could feed everyone
yes there are people who are starving
but it is not the lack of food it is the
lack of love that allows this to happen
there is so much money and so many
riches in the world far more than we
know
if it were all distributed equally
within a month or so those who have
money now would have more and those who
are poor now would once again be poor
for wealth has to do with consciousness
and deservability
there are billions of people on this
planet yet you will hear people tell you
that they are lonely
if we don't reach out love cannot find
us
so as i affirm my self-worth and my
deservability that which i need comes to
me in the perfect time space
availability
the ocean of life is lavish with its
abundance
all my needs and desires are met before
i even ask
my good comes from everywhere and
everyone and everything
all is well in my world
my life has always worked perfectly only
i did not know it i didn't realize that
every negative event in my world was
life reflecting back to me my belief
system
now that i am aware i can consciously
program my thinking process to have a
life that works on all levels
everything in my life works now and
forevermore
my work is deeply fulfilling
when we learn to love what we do then
life sees to it that we will always have
interesting creative occupations
when you are ready emotionally and
mentally for the next step in life life
will move you to it
give your best to life today
i do what i love and love what i do
i know that i am always working in the
right place with just the right people
and that i learn all of the valuable
lessons my soul needs to learn
life supports me when you follow the
laws of life life will support you
abundantly
life created me to be fulfilled i trust
life and life is always there at every
turn i am safe
my future is glorious
our futures will always represent our
current thoughts
what you are thinking and saying right
now is creating your future
so think glorious thoughts and you will
have a glorious future
i now live in limitless love
light and joy all is well in my world
i open new doors to life
as i walk down the corridor of life
there are doors on every side each one
opens to a new experience
the more i clear the negative thought
patterns from my mind the more i find
doors that open to only good experiences
my clarity of thinking brings to me the
best that life has to offer
i rejoice in what i have and i know
fresh new experiences are always ahead
of me i greet the new with open arms i
trust life to be wonderful
i claim my own power and i lovingly
create my own reality
no one can do it for you
only you can make your own declarations
in your mind if you give your power to
others then you have none when you claim
your power it is yours use it wisely
i ask for more understanding so that i
may knowingly and lovingly shape my
world and my experiences
i now create a wonderful new job
bless your current job with love and
release it with love to the next person
who takes your place
knowing that you are moving into a new
level of life
keep your affirmations for the new
position clear and positive and know
that you deserve the best
i am totally open and receptive to a
wonderful new position using my creative
talents and abilities working with and
for people i love in a wonderful
location and earning good money
everything i touch is a success
we always have the option of poverty
thinking or prosperity thinking
when we think thoughts of lack and
limitation then that is what we
experience
there is no way you can be prosperous if
your thinking is impoverished
to be successful you need to constantly
think thoughts of prosperity and
abundance
i now establish a new awareness of
success
i know i can be as successful as i make
my mind up to be
i move into the winning circle
golden opportunities are everywhere for
me prosperity of every kind is drawn to
me
i am open and receptive to new avenues
of income
when we are open and receptive life will
find many ways to bring income to us as
we know and affirm that we deserve all
good the infinite source will open new
channels
we often limit our own good by believing
in fixed income and other closed ideas
opening our consciousness opens the
banks of heaven
i now receive my good from expected and
unexpected sources i am an unlimited
being accepting from an unlimited source
in an unlimited way i am blessed beyond
my fondest dreams
i deserve the best and i accept the best
now
the only thing that keeps us from having
the good in our life is that we don't
believe we deserve it
somewhere in childhood we learned that
we didn't deserve and we believed it
now it is time to release that belief
i am mentally and emotionally equipped
to enjoy a prosperous and loving life
it is my birthright to deserve all good
i claim my good now
[Music]
life is simple and easy
the laws of life are simple far too
simple for many people who want to
struggle and complicate things what you
give out comes back to you what you
believe about yourself and about life
becomes true for you it is that simple
all i need to know at any given moment
is revealed to me i trust myself and i
trust life and all is well what do you
need to do at the conscious level in
order to get the subconscious aligned
when you're making a decision
you're using your conscious brain so
let's say you make a decision you know i
want to write a book i'd like to share
my life story i want to share my um my
passion my interests my lessons uh
what's worked what hasn't worked and
there's something within me that wants
to share right and the reason i write my
books i want to share i want to share
what's worked what hasn't worked and why
um so what happens if you make a
conscious decision
but at the subconscious level you have
um
a disempowering belief for example so
let's say your conscious decisions i
want to write a book i want to share my
knowledge and skills with the world but
underneath the surface you have this
belief this implicit belief that well
who am i to write a book
what do you think is going to happen
if you have this conscious decision but
a subconscious belief
that
maybe you're not smart enough or worthy
enough to write a book who are you
right what do you think happens
when
that goes on in your brain and let me
let me just look at the comments so give
me a comment what do you think happens
you know the goal
that excites you to write a book or to
do anything
um is going to release dopamine in your
brain make you feel good you might even
share it with your um your best friend
your family your husband your wife your
children i want to write a book
but what do you think is going to happen
if in the back of your
mind in the recesses of your brain
you've got a party that says but who are
you to write a book let's say you have a
job right now
and maybe you're happy
fulfilled maybe you're not
and you say you know i'd really like to
start my own business i want to be my
own boss i want to have my own hours and
i want to work 80 hours
to make less than i do in a full-time
job because i want to work for myself
well what if you know in the back
subconscious part of your brain
there's a little voice that says
what if you fail
what if you
don't earn enough income to take care of
yourself your family the things that you
want to do
what if
it takes longer than you anticipate
so can you see how
these conscious decisions part of what
our
brain is wired to these make decisions
um are backed in many instances
with a subconscious mind that is going
to hold us back unless we understand
how to get
our brain to work in coherence so in
addition to your conscious
uh decision-making wanting
brain
if you don't understand the power of the
subconscious which is uh driving 95 plus
percentage of your decisions and your
emotions
chances are you may be having one foot
on the on the gas and another foot on
the brake so the conscious and
subconscious divide
is really really really important when
you have a conscious goal
but you have subconscious patterns like
disempowering beliefs
uh i'm not good enough i'm not smart
enough i'm too young i'm too old you're
gonna have something that we know is
neural chaos there's a part of the brain
that wants the goal in the dream but
another part of the brain that is going
to fight you that's neural chaos and a
brain and chaos will almost always
divert back to its current comfort zone
so if you have limiting beliefs
then you have to learn
how to get rid of your limiting beliefs
you decide you want to achieve a goal
but there's a feeling that you have a
belief that you have that you're not um
good enough and
regardless of where you developed
that belief that you're not good enough
that is part of your subconscious mind
so
when you
repeat the
thought
when you repeat the emotion and when you
don't follow through
with the behaviors necessary to achieve
a goal that you want to achieve
you reinforce
that neural pattern in the brain right
and a belief is nothing more than cells
that have connected that have been
reinforced
a belief is nothing more than neurons
cells that are created through something
called dendrite spiny protuberances the
little pieces on the end that come
together
and connect those are dendrites spiny
protuberances
dsps they're called and when they form
and reinforce the beliefs then drive
perception behaviors emotions etc so
when you have a belief that you know is
a disempowering one at the subconscious
level
here is a really easy first step trick
okay
take that belief write it down except i
want you to do this in a slightly
different way and i want you to do this
because here's what what we know about
the subconscious mind your brain doesn't
know something uh the difference between
something real or imagined
uh and so what i want you to do grace
and for every one of you that wrote down
a a belief that you have that's
disempowering you is put in the past i
used to believe that i wasn't good
enough in the past i used to believe
that i wasn't smart enough in the past i
used to believe
fill in whatever the belief was and now
i'm learning how to feel and be more
than smart enough to achieve my goals so
all you're doing
right a lot of people will teach
um you know if you have a belief that
says you know i'm i'm not good enough
i'm not smart enough
because i'm too young because i'm too
old because i'm too asian or caucasian
or too tall or too short i can't
but if you take that same belief because
when you when you use language patterns
that are certainty based language
pattern which means i'm certain about
this this is the truth
right and then you say okay in the past
i used to believe this is true and now
i'm learning how and you write the
opposite of that what you're doing in
the brain
is instead of saying i am smart
and your brain says no you're not i am
good enough and your brain says no i'm
not you give yourself a bridge between
the two
and this little
inner size using self-talk is in the
past i used to believe this and now i'm
learning how now i'm discovering now i'm
moving towards being smart enough being
good enough being worthy enough etc then
your brain goes oh okay
let me help you find ways to do that
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to learn how to activate the law of
attraction check the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there so when you think a deliberate
thought of what you want
um then law of attraction will employ
the universe
and all people circumstances